well insulin joins us now live from
islamabad in neighboring pakistan and z
um
the death toll is an estimate obviously
given the remoteness of this region is
there a concern that it could climb
significantly
yeah that is the concern and there is no
doubt that that will happen overnight
they were searching in the rubble as you
saw there but there still isn't a robust
search operation in place this is locals
using their bare hands on the ground to
try and find any signs of life to try
and recover any bodies that remain in
the rubble and there will still be
many as you mentioned a hugely remote
area in eastern afghanistan and the
problem is is actually getting aid to
that area yes a lot of it can get to
kabul from countries across the world
but it can't necessarily easily make its
way up to these regions which are
mountainous which are remote and now
which have been destroyed because of
this earthquake you've seen some of the
images there it is incredibly
destructive what's happened and for
afghanistan this is crisis upon crisis
upon crisis we go back to when the
taliban took over last year there has
been famine there has been hunger there
has been the worst drought they've seen
in almost four decades uh financial
sanctions put on by the united states by
the uk and other countries has meant
that this country is amongst some of the
poorest
in the world and now this destructive
earthquake has meant that the taliban
the government the authority in charge
there simply don't have enough
infrastructure in order to deal with
such a natural disaster it's why they've
put a huge plea out to international
authorities to come along to help and to
send as much aid as possible today we
have seen some action some age dripping
through from pakistan some lorries have
gone over the border packed with aid
we've seen two planes come over from
iran qatar have also sent aid into kabul
but again it's that big question of how
do they get all that aid up into those
remote regions this all came as well
jane after quite a poignant moment
yesterday the un secretary general said
that this was a moment for international
solidarity it seemed that the world
listened to what the un uh secretary
general had to say and have responded in
kind but there are still many questions
over this quite gray area of
humanitarian aid and potentially helping
the taliban we've been speaking to a aid
agencies today who've actually said that
there is a bit of hesitancy for
countries like the uk like the united
states to actually send aid to
afghanistan in the fear that they would
actually be aiding the taliban who we
know have been abandoned by a lot of
countries across the world over the last
year they have rejected a lot of notions
from
big countries like the united states
like the uk and that's why some of those
sanctions had been put in place but at
the bottom line there are people
struggling and suffering in these remote
parts of east afghanistan and they need
aid and they need it quickly
okay inzy thanks very much for that